¿Qué pasa, pizarritas? Hoy nos mojamos con los pronósticos de la Champions League, aunque lo vamos a hacer solo de la fase de Ligilla, porque ya cuando esté la fase de Ligilla concluida y tengamos un poquito el bracket con la repesca y demás, ya nos mojaremos con todo el cuadro, pero es un poquito absurdo.
Creo que lo que hicimos el año pasado de dar ya una final sin saber por qué lado del cuadro va a ir cada uno.
Así que hoy nos mojamos con la fase Ligilla, top 8, top 24 y mejores futbolistas.
Adrien Blanco, Alex De Llano, Nahuel Miranda, ¿estáis preparados?
Vamos a ello, ¿qué tal chicos?
Siempre ready.
¿Qué tal?
Hoy creo que, o sea, creo que esto es bastante más fácil, este ejercicio es bastante más sencillo que el de la Liga.
¿Lo quiero decir?
Sí.
¿No?
A ver, a ver, a ver.
El año pasado, el año pasado de los 24, creo que acertamos todos 22, 23, creo que el Brest no lo acertamos, que nos dejamos al Girona fuera, el RLIC, creo.
Bueno, pero si este formato venía a cambiar, ¿no?
Estas fases de grupos que no...
Pues ya empieza el relato.
Los clásicos, vuelven los clásicos.
Ha vuelto la campeona.
Me he traído mi camiseta del Inter, tal.
A ver, lo primero que os voy a preguntar, porque os voy a pedir luego el top 8 en orden, ¿vale?
Y el top 24 sin orden, porque es un poco bajar.
Pero os quiero preguntar, ¿qué español situáis primero?
Entiendo que algunos se meterán en el top 8, pero ¿qué español Adrián Blanco quedará mejor clasificado en la fase de Ligilla?
Solo fase de Ligilla.
El Fútbol Club Barcelona.
¿Ales de Llano?
¿Nauel Miranda?
Eh...
Lleva al Barça yo también, pero no...
Es que esto...
A ver, yo también llevo al Barça porque ya dije en su momento...
Entre Barça y Real Madrid tiene el sorteo más sencillo del Barça.
Eso es lo que pensamos nosotros.
Hay mucha gente que no lo ve de esa manera, pero bueno.
Bueno, bueno, podemos hablar de la hostia monumental que sorteó Adrián Blanco con este tema.
¡Ja!
Estuvo bicheando, eh.
¡Ay, no me lo fue, tío!
Estuvo con la Lupita, estuvo con la Lupita.
¡Ahí, Lupita!
Los cuatro situamos al Barça en el Top 8.
Eh... quiero un adelanto, Adri.
¿Hay algún otro...?
Bueno, he dicho en el Top 8.
El que queda mejor, ¿no?
Entiendo que el Barça está en vuestro Top 8.
Sí.
¿Cuántos españoles hay en tu Top 8, Adrián Blanco?
Dos.
¿Nau?
Tres.
¿Alex?
Yo llevo dos.
Venga, vamos con el Top 8 en orden a Cañón.
Si hay alguna cosita que me queréis ir explicando por el camino,
tema de calendario que yo lo he estado mirando mucho, sensaciones, lo que sea,
pues lo decís.
Adri.
Ya abajo arriba.
Del octavo al primero, ¿no?
Venga.
Octavo, Benfica.
Séptimo, Nápoles.
Sexto, Chelsea.
Quinto, Arsenal.
Cuarto, Real Madrid.
Tercero, Bayern.
Segundo, Barça.
Y primero, Liverpool.
No has metido al Paris Saint-Germain, ¿verdad?
No.
Tiene el calendario más complicado.
El Bayern sí. El Bayern está tercero.
El calendario del Paris Saint-Germain es una salvajada.
Sí.
Es el tercero más complicado de todas las...
Duro, duro.
Según Opta.
Una mierda.
Opta se ha hecho un perolón.
El famoso Súper Ordenador.
El PSG.
Parece Súper el de Gran Hermano.
O sea, el PSG, os digo, empieza contra Atalanta en casa.
Va a...
Bueno, a Barcelona, porque no sabemos dónde va a ir.
A Lederkusen.
PSG, Bayern.
Esas son las cuatro primeras jornadas.
Pero es que la quinta es PSG, Tottenham.
La sexta es, en San Mames, Atleti Club PSG.
La séptima es Sporting de Portugal PSG.
Que es un poco el partido quizá más sencillo, pero fíjate.
Y la octava es PSG, Newcastle.
O sea, es...
Dijente campeón.
Que sí, pero no es el tercer calendario más complicado ni de coñas.
Es imposible un calendario más difícil.
Pone más complicado el del Bayern.
Porque es Chelsea en casa.
Tiene PSG y Arsenal fuera.
Es que pesan mucho aquí todo lo de fuera.
O sea, los rivales más complicados del PSG son en casa, ¿no?
El Newcastle es en casa.
El Tottenham es en casa.
El Barça fuera.
Y el Atleti Club fuera de casa.
Sí, pero uno.
Aquí es que le dan más complicación a visitar al Arsenal que...
Ya, ya.
Vale.
O sea, entiendo cómo lo plantean.
Vale, vale.
Me gusta porque Adrián Blanco y yo no vamos a coincidir.
Así que...
Me he esforzado para ello.
Me he esforzado.
Mesismo, bien, bien.
Persamente...
Adrián ha hecho lo primero que iba a hacer y ha dicho...
Claro, claro.
He trabajado doble.
Vale.
¿Tu top tres era cuál?
Liverpool, Barça, Bayern.
Vale.
¿Ales de Llano?
De abajo arriba, ¿eh?
Atlético de Madrid.
Bayern.
Manchester City.
Real Madrid.
Barça.
PSG.
Liverpool.
Y Arsenal.
Yo he pensado ahí en el Arsenal, ¿eh?
Pero tiene todo el calendario complicado.
El Arsenal el año pasado hizo la mejor fase o una de las mejores fases de grupos.
Yo creo que el calendario tampoco es muy tal, ¿no?
Es verdad que empieza en San Mamés.
Luego tiene Marsella, ¿no?
Atlético de Madrid en casa.
Eslabia.
Barça en casa...
Bayern en casa, perdón.
Y luego tiene Inter fuera y acaba contra el Kairat en casa.
No me parece tampoco...
Yo diría nivel intermedio quizás, ¿no?
Opta lo pone como el segundo más fácil.
Ah, interesante.
El segundo más fácil.
El más fácil de hecho se lo pone al...
Al...
Al Copenhague.
Porque tiene el Karabach, tiene el Kairat...
Y bueno, tiene Valle de Verkúsen en casa...
O sea, bueno, tiene como varios así un poco.
Nahuel Miranda de Armas.
Eh...
Buena, buena.
Buena tralla.
Es que estoy dudando aquí última hora, ¿eh?
¿Quieres que lo diga yo primero?
Eh...
No, no he metido a quien tú crees.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Digo que si quieres que diga lo mío primero para darte tiempo.
Sí, sí, sí, sí. Me gusta, me gusta, me gusta.
Es que...
No.
He sufrido un cambio...
Teniendo expectaciones, ¿eh?
He sufrido un cambio terrible.
Vale, vale.
Mi top 8.
Arsene al octavo.
Tottenham séptimo, que creo que no lo habéis nombrado ninguno.
No.
He visto el calendario y eh, ¿palante?
O sea, la verdad es que esto es mi girona, ¿vale?
De la conference.
Sí, la verdad que sí.
Lo acepto, lo admito y vamos para adelante.
Thomas Frank, para adelante.
Paris Saint-Germain.
Real Madrid.
Cuarto.
Es el Napoli.
Que creo que tiene un calendario...
De los que yo entiendo...
Tiene City la primera jornada afuera.
Por eso, un calendario fácil.
Chelsea en casa.
Sí, Chelsea en casa.
Bayern Munich tercero, segundo Barça, primero Liverpool.
Te preguntaba tu top 3, Adri, porque...
Hemos cambiado, pero no lo es suficiente.
No lo es suficiente.
Vale, vale.
Bueno, bueno, bueno.
A ver...
Has metido al City, tú tampoco.
No he metido al City.
Tú tampoco.
No he metido al Atlético de Madrid.
No he metido al Arsenal.
Así no, al Arsenal, sí.
Perdona, al Ayube.
No he metido al Benfica.
Yo tampoco.
Y no he metido al Inter de Milán, que creo que vosotros tampoco.
Tampoco.
Es que no confío en nada.
De hecho, lo he metido en el 24, pero un poco...
Porque...
Por descarte.
Porque tiene que entrar otro, ¿sabes?
Pero no me fío nada.
Nau.
Eh...
¿Entre qué dudabas?
No, no, no.
Había metido al Sporting y lo he dejado afuera.
No.
Octavo es el Arsenal.
Es importante que recordes que el octavo es el Arsenal, ¿vale?
Porque luego me sirve para explicar otro programa.
Nápoles, Villarreal, Paris, Saint-Germain, Liverpool,
tercero en Real Madrid, segundo Chelsea, primero Barça.
¡Ostras!
¡El Villarreal!
Y el Chelsea ahí, ¿eh?
El Villarreal tiene una explicación.
Creo que empieza contra los rivales más complicados.
Sí.
Vale más o menos.
Creo que está...
¿Crees que eso es mejor?
¿Cómo?
No lo sé, yo también me lo he planteado.
En un buen momento creo que le pilla bien esto al Villarreal.
Tiene...
Bueno, visita Londres, para el Jorde de la Tottenham,
recibe a Juve y a Manchester City, luego tiene Pafos y Dortmund fuera,
Copenhague y Ajax en casa, Leverkusen a domicilio.
Es decir, que Leverkusen...
Ya en enero.
Sí, pero vamos, me deja satisfecho meter al Villarreal en el top 8.
¿Y quién te deja...?
O sea, ¿no has metido al Atlético de Madrid, claro?
No he metido al Bayern, no he metido al Dortmund,
no he metido al Atlético de Madrid, no he metido al Inter,
no he metido a la Juve, no he metido al Manchester City,
no he metido al Tottenham...
Vale, vale, vale.
Digno de Fútbol Manager, eh.
Sí, al París de Jermel lo llevo quinto.
Al City, solamente...
Realmente, el orden...
Sí, sí, sí.
¿Al City quién lo ha metido?
¿Sólo ha habido uno que lo ha metido?
Yo lo he metido sexto.
Vale.
Y yo he sido el único que ha metido al Tottenham, ¿verdad?
Sí.
Vale.
No...
A ver, insisto, asumo.
Asumo...
Asumo el triple.
Vale.
Top 24.
Sin orden, ¿vale?
Yo he ordenado alfabéticamente según la clasificación que iba viendo,
la verdad, por no perderme...
Yo lo he hecho con orden, pero tampoco es un orden, ¿sabes?
O sea, es un orden que he hecho.
Bueno, me cuadra.
Vale.
Eh...
¿Queréis que...?
Dale.
Voy diciendo mi lista y vais diciendo si lo tenéis o no,
así queda más interesante y no nos perdemos.
A ver, venga, me voy apuntando, va.
Vale.
Atalanta.
Atalanta...
No.
Espera.
No habéis metido ninguno a Atalanta.
No.
Vale, vale, vale.
No confiamos en el juego, Asperini.
Atletic Club.
Sí.
Vale.
Atlético de Madrid.
Sí.
Yo es que lo tengo en la primera.
Benfica.
Sí.
Lo tengo en el 8, yo.
Borussia Dortmund.
Sí.
No.
¡Opá!
Se quedó.
Se cae, se cae el Dortmund.
A ver, viene siendo muy crítico, Nao, con el Dortmund.
La de Fabio Silva ha sido top, la que han liado.
Brujas.
No.
Brujas...
¿Tú, Nao?
Yo sí.
A mí, el calendario que he visto luego, el Brujas siempre está ahí, así que...
Amantimaciolis y tal.
Chelsea.
Eso es verdad.
Chelsea sí.
Lo tengo en el 8, 8-8.
Para mí no ven, de hecho.
Vale.
Galatasaray.
Sí.
No.
Sí, sí.
¿Quién ha dicho no?
Yo.
Adri.
Enmigo de la diversión.
Inter de Milán.
Sí.
Lo he metido, pero a disgusto un poco, ¿eh?
Juventus.
Sí.
City.
No, lo tengo en el primero.
Marsella.
Sí.
No.
Joder, Nao, ¿eh?
Mónaco.
Mónaco, vaya guadaña.
Mónaco sí, el último.
Para mí.
No, yo tampoco llevo Mónaco.
Antifrancés, bien, bien.
¿Te vas a marcar un Paphos?
No, bueno, el más raro que llevo es el Vodo.
Vale, vale, vale.
Ahora me dices.
Mola, mola.
Newcastle.
Sí.
Olimpiakos.
No.
Y Villarreal, que bueno, Nao no.
Sí, yo Villarreal.
Sí.
O sea, una conclusión que empiezo sacando.
Todos damos a los cinco españoles en el Top 24.
Sí.
Vale, vale, vale, vale.
Esta es mi lista con vuestros sí y vuestros no.
Adri, ¿qué nombres que yo no he metido has metido tú?
Paris Saint-Germain, entrar en todo de mi Top 24.
Bayer Leverkusen, Eintracht de Frankfurt, PSV y Tottenham.
Vale, claro, yo es que no he confiado nada en los alemanes.
El Eintracht tiene un calendario súper complicado.
Yo la he entrado en el Top 24.
Es imposible que gare la Champions que me entra.
Álex, ¿qué diferentes tienes tú?
Mira, yo he metido el Napoli en el Top 24,
que creo que vosotros lo habéis puesto en el Top 8.
No me satisface mucho, ¿eh?
El Napoli es el apaño que he hecho última hora en el Top 8,
pero no me convence.
Yo comenté la primera jornada, la he ganado la segunda y tal.
Bueno, a ver, conté precisamente en Champions,
no he metido nada en el Top 24.
Tottenham, Sporting de Portugal, Ajax y PSV.
Ajax, uf, yo en el Ajax no he confiado nada.
Yo tampoco, me lo he cargado todo.
Ya lo sé, pero...
Realmente acabamos antes hablando de lo que nos hemos cargado,
que yo, a nivel de nombres gordos,
yo me he cargado Aldo Ormund, Alemán Leverkusen,
Ajax, Pérez de Madrid,
y también, por supuesto, el Eintracht.
Aldo Ormund, Alemán Leverkusen, Ajax,
Olympique de Marsella, Guayatabanda y Mónaco.
Me los he cargado. Guadañazo.
¿Qué tiene? Repasa tus 24, porque, joder,
es que no me salen las cuentas.
Eintracht, Bodo, Benfica, Bayern, Athletic Club,
Atlético de Madrid, Brujas, Inter, Juve,
Sporting de Portugal, Manchester City, Olimpiakos,
PSV, Tottenham, Galatasaray, Newcastle.
Sí, o sea, se cola el Bodo.
Yo veo sentido. No puedo cuadrar.
Bueno. Está bien.
Yo soy el único que ha metido al Bodo, ¿no?
Sí, sí. Yo he sido el único que ha metido a la Atalanta.
Yo creo que soy el único que ha metido a Benfica en el Top 8.
El año pasado me venía el triple del Esparta de Praga,
me salió bastante mal. Yo confío un poquito más en el Bodo.
¿Y hay alguno, Álex, que tú hayas metido al Top 24 que nadie?
¿La Ajax?
Yo a la Ajax no. Quizás. Yo tampoco.
Pues la Ajax. Los dos son las de ese realmente, he metido.
Sí, pero nada más me queda el PSV.
Y yo, aunque el PSV creo que me lo voy a comer con patatas.
Yo he visto un calendario del PSV muy complicado.
El PSV, las cuatro últimas jornadas es Amphil,
Athletic en casa, Newcastle fuera y Bayern en casa.
Qué pereza ir mirando todos los puñetes de los calendarios.
Lo peor, ¿sabes lo peor, Nau?
Que es imposible acordarse. Esos minutos que hemos dedicado a eso
no han servido para nada.
Para nada. A mí me ha ayudado mucho.
Opta valora la dificultad del calendario
de acuerdo al rating que le dan ellos dentro de su propio ranking
a los equipos y tienen un cuadro
que es el que más le gusta.
Y es el que más le gusta.
Hay un cuadro en el que pone PSV
y te pone todos los rivales.
Bayern, pum, pum, pum.
No he tenido que ir al transfer mark.
PSV, Bayern.
Bueno, bastantes diferencias.
Mola, mola.
Es imposible hacer esto.
Si hemos puesto al Barça más arriba,
si vamos a poner al Barça más abajo,
es simplemente por la ley del AKE, que es la que me cuelga.
Porque no hay ningún tipo de lógica ni razonamiento ni nada.
No busquéis algo muy loceso.
Ni filias ni fobias.
De triple en triple.
Yo te iba a decir, no te justifiques,
pero no ha sido una justificación.
No ha sido la teoría del AKE.
Me ha gustado.
Tres preguntas individuales para finalizar.
Y así a Enrique hacer un poquito los pronósticos.
Si no, esto queda un poquito...
¿Cómo es lo contrario?
Sin sal.
Insípido, ¿no?
Soso.
Buen equipo, francés.
Menos mal.
¿Qué jugador marcará más goles en la fase de liguilla?
Pido paso.
¿Os acordáis? Arsenal octavo.
Me he ido al calendario del Kairat Almaty.
Qué grande.
Que juega la última jornada en el Emirates.
Ese Arsenal ahí...
El gola me da ese.
Yo querés.
Un carro.
Tiene facilidad para hacer goles contra estos equipos lamentables.
Haaland contra Moldavia.
Moldavia, sí.
No tenía una idea, pero cuando he visto...
El calendario del Kairat Almaty fuera de casa.
Tiene muchísimo sentido.
Si el Arsenal está en el alambre,
es un partido en el que debería poder golar.
Alex.
Yo me he ido a tablero.
Es un jugador que va a jugar contra el Kairat.
Es Kilian Mbappé.
Le veo fino, le veo bien.
Empieza la liga marcando.
Es Mbappé.
Tampoco teje.
Adri.
Mbappé.
Yo me quedo con...
El rey de la fase de grupo es el Bayern.
Siempre su delantero.
Ahora Harry Kane marca muchos goles.
A tope.
Juegadorazo.
El Bayern tiene su típico partido en casa.
Tengo aquí un Bayern-Union Saint-Giloua.
Séptima jornada.
Para un hat-trick.
El año pasado es Girassi 10.
Levandowski 9.
En la fase de grupos.
Yo tengo Girassi 10.
Girassi 10.
La fase liguilla.
Esto cuenta la fase previa.
Girassi 10.
Levandowski 9.
Jalan 8.
Raffiña 8.
Mbappé, Kane, Vinicius 7.
¿Qué jugador dará más asistencias?
Es difícil.
En la liga tú vas con la Mín-Jamal.
¿Qué haces?
Me he quedado con Florian Birch.
No ha empezado muy allá.
La segunda parte contrarreloj será la mejor.
Yo he puesto a Olise.
¿No has dicho la Mín?
No, era por el batallón.
No, no.
Olise está muy enterado.
Cuando estás en la radio, se te pega.
Todo lo malo se pega.
¿Nau?
Bucallo, Osaka.
Muchísimas dudas.
Olin, Adarsenal.
Me gusta un poco él.
Mira, es el que me gusta.
Hay un rey de revertir asistencias
en horas bajas.
He metido en el top 8.
Ha cambiado de club.
Muy buena.
Vamos a tirar con Kevin.
Qué mal me caes, hijo.
Un poquito de sangre.
Le va a venir bien estar en Nápoles.
Yo he metido a Mered.
Por calendario,
Nápoli, equipo que encaja poco.
A tope con Mered.
En esta fase de Ligilla
tenemos presentes
a tres porteros que están
más pugnantes.
En el equipo de Nápoles
hay tres porteros que están
más pugnantes.
Joan García, por su paso al Barça,
David Raya, por sus grandes actuaciones
con la selección y el Arsenal.
Unai Simón, el portero titular ahora mismo.
Me he ido por la opción impopular
de las tres que he mencionado.
David Raya.
La gente no va a darse.
El equipo que va a defender mejor
va en concordancia con mis pronósticos.
El Arsenal va a estar arriba
porque su defensa va a funcionar bien.
He de decir que lo he cambiado.
Esta mañana tenía a Joan.
Volviendo en el metro, creo que David Raya
está mejor protegido.
En una carrera de Fórmula 1
hay pilotos que van el 14º.
Parece que va a llover y se tira en el triplín.
Voy metiendo los neumáticos de mojado
a ver si caen cuatro gotas.
Soy aquí el puto amo.
Me voy a quedar con Luis Junior.
Toma ya.
Me quedaría.
Me he metido neumáticos de lluvia
en Torrevieja en agosto.
No me importa demasiado.
Pero sí.
No me convencé ninguno.
He metido el Villarreal arriba.
Va a defender de locos el Villarreal.
Me quedo con Luis Junior.
Volaría a jugar a Diego Conde la Champions.
En realidad no le hubieran marcado ningún gol.
A ver.
Por qué no me lo he goleado?
No pones que haya que jugar un mínimo de minutos.
Yo me he quedado con Alisson.
He puesto primero a Liverpool.
Veo a Liverpool muy favorito para la Champions.
Como juego de mamardas.
La teoría de Nahuel.
Pronósticos finos.
De esta paselillilla.
Pronósticos a chulón.
Venga, pronóstica.
Vente de pronóstico.
Como es ese pizarrita.
Pizarritus.
Puedes poner tus pronósticos en la pizarrita.
Puedes poner tus pronósticos en la cajita de comentarios.
Pasadnos cuentas en enero cuando acabe la fase de la lillilla.
No, no, cállate.
Y entonces haremos el bracket con la repesca.
Gracias, pizarritas.
Mañana más.
No sabemos si mejor, porque no sé qué vídeo sale.
Gracias.